Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday. So in the middle of all the misery of human life it's easy to
forget that there is much worth celebrating and as we begin a new year I
thought it would be nice to start it off with some good news.
Like for instance, divorce rate in the US have gone down every year since 2006 and
are currently at their lowest level since 1970.
Then there's pregnancy, which from what I can gather is not fun.
The global rate of unintended pregnancy has declined dramatically since 1995 when 69 out of 1000 women
had unintended pregnancies. In 2008 it was 55 in 1000 women which is good news
because unintended pregnancies can have all kinds of health consequences
for infants and for mothers including increased infant mortality.
Which reminds me that infant mortality is at an all-time low.
Worldwide, it has dropped from 46 deaths per 1,000 births to 35 just in the last eight years.
Now of course, you're worried that we're going to have like seventy gajillion humans on Earth,
but in fact, when infant mortality declines, families have fewer children.
So decreasing infant mortality actually helps the overall population of humans stabilize,
which is good because there are already too many of you driving up the price of the playoff tickets
from our hometown Indianapolis Colts going to the playoffs! More good news.
But in more important good news, absolute poverty is down worldwide. In fact, the United Nations estimates
that poverty has decreased more in the last fifty years than it did in the previous five hundred.
So much for the idea that colonization is good for the colonized.
Adjusted for inflation, the number of people living on less than $1.25 a day has decreased from
43% in 1990 to 20% today. Now most of that is due to gains in China and India and Brazil.
However, sub-Saharan Africa, long the world's poorest region, has been growing much faster than the world
economy for the past decade. Now inequality of wealth remains a huge problem around the world,
but in the vast majority of countries, the poor are becoming less poor.
Also, there is good news for those of us in the developed world. In the United States, cancer mortality rates have
dropped by 20% in the last 25 years. Why? Well, mostly because people quit smoking, or died from smoking.
But also, we have better treatments and screenings for colon and breast cancers and a bunch of others.
Then there's the Internet, which is reaching more people at higher speeds. In the US, Internet speeds were up
27% in 2013 over 2012. In fact, they were up all around the world, from Guatemala, 75% increase,
to Thailand, 32%. So it's easier than ever for people to stay in touch and to collaborate.
It's also easier than ever to visit one another. While being herded like cattle into a steel cylinder
and rocketed through the air remains one of the least pleasant experiences that a human being can have,
airfares have dropped by almost 50% since 1985. You can also fly to more places than ever before,
and it's never been safer. Speaking of safe traveling, let's talk about cars.
For every 100 million miles driven in the US in 2011, there was 1.1 vehicular fatality.
In 1980, that number was 3.5. If you take 1980 as your baseline, safer cars and safer drivers saved
60,000 American lives in 2013. That's pretty great. Also things are getting better for nonhuman animals.
Well, at least the ones that we've domesticated. Back in the 1990s, 17 million cats and dogs were euthanized
per year in the US. Now that number is closer to 5 million. What else? Well, the fight against malaria
is working, with mortality rates down nearly 50% in the last ten years.
More girls are attending school around the world and the literacy rate for women in their twenties has risen
from 79% in 1990 to 87% today. And in almost every country on Earth, you are more likely to live to be old
than you were ten years ago. You are less likely to be hungry and you are likely better connected to those
you love. Hank, ten years ago, we couldn't have had this conversation because there was no YouTube.
The Nerdfighter community couldn't have raised more than three quarters of a million dollars for charity
because there was no Nerdfighter community.
Now of course, this progress is tenuous, and much of it is unsustainable with current technology,
but it's also real and it's worth celebrating. So here's to a new year, Hank. May it really and truly be
the best one yet. Happy New Year!
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.